There's a fundamental truth about LLMs, large
language models. They are frozen in time. They
know everything about our world up until
their training cutoff date and absolutely
nothing about what happened 5 minutes ago. Nor
do they know anything about your private data,
your internal wikis, your proprietary codebase. And
if we do want an LLM to know any of that stuff,
well, we have to solve the problem of context
injection. How do we get the right data into the
model at the right time? And there have been two
very different ways to handle this. Now, the first
is really what we can think of as the engineering
approach. It's RAG, retrieval augmented generation.
So here we've got an LLM and we've also got an
input prompt from the user. Now ahead of time
we take some of the documents that we want to give
to this LLM. So these are documents that could be
PDFs or code files or entire books and we chunk
them. We break them up into smaller chunks and
we pass them through to an embedding model and
the embedding model takes those chunks and it
turns them into vectors and those vectors are then
stored in a dedicated vector database. Now when a
user asks a question, it performs a semantic
search to retrieve the most relevant chunks
and then inject them into the context window.
So now the context window has the user prompt,
but it also has all of these chunks that we have
taken from the vector database and together this
forms the context window. Now this works but
it does rely on something. It relies on the
hope that your retrieval logic actually found
the right information in the vector database.
Now the the second approach is really a bit more
of a brute force approach and that one is called
long context. Now this is really the model native
solution because you skip the database here and
you skip the embedding model. All you do is you
take your documents and you just well you put them
straight into the context window and then you let
the model's attention mechanism actually do the
heavy lifting of finding the answer. Now for a
long time this kind of brute force method wasn't
really much of an option because initially context
windows were tiny. Early LLMs had context windows
that could maybe store what like 4K of tokens.
You couldn't fit a novel in there, let alone a
corporate knowledge base. You basically had to use
RAG. But today's models have much larger context
windows. Some of them have, you know, a million
tokens plus. And to put that into perspective,
a million tokens is roughly 700,000 words. and you
could fit the entire Lord of the Rings series into
the prompt and still have room for The Hobbit. So,
this massive jump in capacity forces us to ask a
difficult question about our architecture. Because
if we can simply command A, command C, command V,
all of our documentation into the models context
window, do we really need the overhead of
embedding models and vector data stores? Is RAG
becoming an unnecessary complexity layer? Well,
if we accept that we can fit whatever data we
need into the context window, then the argument
for doing so basically boils down to one word,
simplicity. And let me give you three reasons why
stuffing the context window directly may indeed be
the way to go. And reason number one is collapsing
the infrastructure. A production RAG system. Well,
it is quite heavy. You need a a chunking strategy
which is like fixed size maybe or sliding window
or recursive. You decide. You're going to need
a embedding model to encode the data. You need
a a vector database to store it. You're going
to need a reranker to sort the results. you need
to keep all the vectors in sync with your source
data. It's basically a lot of moving parts, a lot
of places for things to break. And long context
offers what we might call well just simply the uh
the no stack stack. You remove the database, you
remove the embeddings, you remove the retrieval
logic. The architecture simplifies down to getting
the data and just well sending it to the model. So
that's reason number one. Reason number two is the
retrieval lottery. Now, RAG introduces a critical
point of failure here, the retrieval step itself,
because when a user asks a question, RAG looks at
mathematical representations of the data, which are
stored in vectors. And vectors are basically
just like a really long series of numbers in
an array. And it tries to find the closest
match. That's semantic search. But semantic
search is probabilistic and for all manner of
reasons, the retrieval might fail to find the
relevant document. And we actually have a name
for this. It's called silent failure. The answer,
well, it existed in the data, but the LLM never
saw it because the retrieval step didn't return
the right results. With long context, there is no
retrieval step. The model gets to see everything.
Now, reason number three that is well, I think
we're going to call this the whole book problem.
A RAG is fundamentally designed to retrieve
what exists. It relies on finding a semantic
match between your query and a specific snippet
of text in your database. But what if the answer
lies in what's not in the database? So, so let's
say you have a set of product requirements stored
as a document and you've also got a set of release
notes stored as a document and then we ask which
security requirements were omitted from the final
release. Now using RAG when you query for omitted
security requirements the vector search looks for
chunks discussing well security and requirements.
It retrieves snippets from the requirements doc.
It retrieves snippets from the release notes,
but it cannot retrieve the gap between them. And
because RAG only shows the model a few isolated
snapshots, the model never sees the full picture
required to spot the missing pieces. The model
really needs both of these documents in full to
perform the comparison, which is exactly what
long context does by dumping the whole book, the
full requirements doc and the full release notes
into the context window. So, is RAG dead? Is the
vector database destined for the museum of things
we needed in 2024? Well, not quite because while
long context wins on simplicity, RAG still has a
place. And I got another three reasons to support
that. So, reason number one is the rereading text.
Now, long context creates a massive compute
inefficiency. So, if we take a manual, let's say
this is like a a 500 page manual, and we've got to
turn this into tokens. Well, that's something like
250k of tokens. And we need to do that every time
we make a user query and we put this document in
the prompt. You're basically requiring the model
to process that manual every time. Now, RAG also
has to process that manual, but it only pays that
processing cost once at indexing time. Now, prompt
caching that can partially offset some of this for
static data, but for dynamic data streams where
content changes frequently, you are stuck paying
the full tax on every request. Reason number two
is the needle in the haystack problem. Now,
there's a an intuitive assumption that if data
is in the context window, the model's probably
going to use it, but research suggests otherwise.
Because as we start with a context window and then
it grows and it continues to grow and now we're at
like 500,000 tokens, well, the model's attention
mechanism can get a bit diluted. If you ask a
specific question about a single paragraph that's
buried in, let's say, the middle of a 2,000 page
document, well, the model often fails to retrieve
it or it hallucinates details from the surrounding
text. But with RAG, we're giving the model less
noise. So by retrieving, say only the top five
relevant chunks, RAG has removed the haystack
and presents the model with just the needles.
It forces the model to focus on the signal and
not the noise. And then reason number three,
well that is the infinite data set. Now a context
window of millions of tokens sounds great but in
the scheme of enterprise data that's really just a
drop in the bucket. I mean an enterprise data lake
that's probably measured in terabytes or or maybe
even petabytes. So if you want an infinite data
set that stores everything, you really do need to
have a retrieval layer to filter information down
to something that fits into the LLM context
window. So where does this leave us? Well,
if your problem involves a bounded data set and
requires complex global reasoning like analyzing
a specific legal contract or summarizing a book, I
think long context is the way to go. It simplifies
the stack and it improves the reasoning. But
if you're navigating the infinite data set of
enterprise knowledge, the vector database remains
the only viable warehouse for your data. But how
about you? Are you team long context, team RAG,
maybe a bit of both? Let me know in the comments.